another disturbing story out of an
elementary school in oregon
oregon gosh
that place a lot of stories coming out
of oregon
fourth graders at raleigh hills
elementary school
located in beaverton
oregon
were just presented with a slideshow a
couple of weeks ago daily wire just
learned this
unveiling the formation of a qsa club
that's queer what is it queer sexuality
alliance something to that effect
so there's a there's an lgbt club for
fourth graders in this school
and the lgbt club is recruiting the
students and it's being presented to the
students
and the parents have no idea there is no
parental consent required one of the
slides from this club it says
what will we do we'll have conversations
about identity gender equal rights and
social issues that are important to you
we'll explore lgbtq plus
history and activism we will discuss
personal struggles now we're getting
real creepy we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna groom you kids is what it is
what they're
implying
we're gonna discuss personal struggles
and successes in a supportive space
we're going to advocate for change
in our school and community
but we're going to advocate for change
changing what
we're going to talk about your personal
struggles in the sexuality club for
nine-year-olds
what personal struggles if you are
having
personal struggles in your sexual
relationships at nine
you should be recommended to a school
counselor
this should be discouraged
nine-year-olds shouldn't be doing that
but instead it's being encouraged and
the parents have no right to say
anything about it
and frankly
by the logic of
our culture right now
really by the logic of all cultures and
societies
given the premises we're starting with
there's actually no reason for the
parents to be involved this is something
that conservatives don't quite
understand about there's really no
reason for the conservatives to be
involved if you accept all the radical
premises
to begin with so these creepy pervert
degenerate administrators at an
elementary school in oregon are
recruiting their nine-year-old kids to
join lgbtq club and convince little
johnny that he's really little jane this
is obviously very creepy very wrong the
people who are pushing this should
certainly be fired if not prosecuted
and the the part that everyone's
focusing on
is that the parents weren't even
informed
the parents were that like that's the
worst part of this
i understand why people are focusing on
parental consent as the because not only
the left but also the right now believes
that consent
is the be-all and end-all of politics
and there's there's nothing deeper that
we can talk about it's all just about
procedure
we all just need to consent and if you
want to consent to mutilate your body or
do a ton of drugs or or whatever that's
totally fine but you've got to make sure
that you get consent all they care about
is procedural norms you see this even in
some pro-life advocacy where they say
look i'm not telling new yorkers and
californians that they need to ban
abortion i'm just saying the supreme
court has no right to do it so we've got
to send it back to the states and then
if the people want to kill a zillion
babies a year in illinois that's totally
fine but it's not totally fine the
procedure matters it's true the court
shouldn't take rights away from the
states and from the people but the
substance matters too we also shouldn't
kill babies
yes the procedure matters parents should
have a say over their kids education
obviously parents should have some say
in how their kids are raised but the
substance matters too
namely
we shouldn't be teaching kids
gender theory when they're nine years
old pretending that all sorts of
eccentric sexual ideologies are totally
fine
probably the only the only sexual
ideology that you're not allowed to
teach in this elementary school is that
men are not women and men should should
mary should marry women and they should
live in a monogamous household for life
and have a family and procreate that i
bet you would be taken to court if you
taught that in this school but you can
teach everything else why the reason for
this it actually makes perfect sense
is that well we often think
that our substantive views
are downstream of procedural norms
very often it's the opposite
i'm using sort of technical language
here so what i mean by that is we think
that the things we actually believe
about what is good and true and
beautiful
come downstream of how we come to decide
them is it the court is it the we the
people this is it the teachers is it the
pta is that we all come together and we
deliberate and then we form our
substantive views out of that but very
often it's the opposite
very often it's the things that we think
are good and true and beautiful
that decide how we decide other
questions
so our culture has decided
that
lgbtq plus there are now 5000 other
letters to it
is
good
true
and completely beyond debate
not even just that you know two fellas
like each other on a navy ship out at
sea and you know that's one thing no
we're saying that even the t
okay we're we're talking about
boys can chop up their bodies and pump
themselves full of hormones and actually
become women that in our culture is
considered unassailable if you question
that in your job in your school
you can be kicked out you can be kicked
out of both of those places you can
certainly be punished
and depending on how you do it you might
even be charged with a crime
there was a bill in california
signed into law in 2017 that said that
if health care workers misgender quote
unquote their patients
they could be prosecuted
misgender meaning properly gender
meaning there's a man who thinks he's a
woman and the healthcare worker says
hello sir
that healthcare worker could be
prosecuted according to the law now it's
been
extremely controversial since it was
passed but
we have decided that that is the case so
of course if lgbtq is totally fine and
unassailable and beyond reproach and
beyond debate
then why why would you need the parent's
permission
why would you allow some bigoted hateful
false-minded parent
to
question something that we as a culture
have decided is unquestionable
we've we've concluded the substantive
issue
and so the procedure is going to change
whereas 10 years ago
you would have needed at least to get a
parent's permission slip for a club like
this probably you wouldn't even have a
club like this
today that's been decided
we live
in a society
the only way to have a society is for
certain things to be settled we need to
speak the same language we need to
believe
many of the many if not most of the same
things we need to
have have plenty of areas of the public
discourse where you you just take
everything for granted that's the only
that's how all societies work
and the left understands this which is
how they've completely transformed what
we believe and the right refuses to
understand this and they bury their head
in the sands
and they say well i'm not going to force
my opinions on you
uh you do you and i'll do me and i just
support individual freedom
and it's not really freedom at all it
just gives the left the whole playing
ground do you not get enough respect
i'll tell you me i get no respect no
respect i tell you well that was true
before i became a lord that's right i am
lord michael knowles i can prove it i've
got my certificate from established
titles which is a terrific way to play
on an old scottish custom to to refer to
landowners as lards or lords and ladies
in english with established titles you
will get your title pack you will
receive at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate and
an official certificate with a crest
with your certificate you can officially
change your name to lord or lady you can
get it on your credit card or airplane
tickets you can put it on your dating
profiles it's a great way to connect
with your family if you happen to be
scottish it's a great way to get some
respect if you're like me and it helps
to
preserve nature because established
titles has partnered with a lot of
really great conservation charities so
you're helping the planet while you do
it they're having an extended new year
sale right now head on over to
establishtitles.com
save 10 off today remember to use the
discount code knowles kles or just click
the link below that is established
titles dot com slash knowles we should
change that url though it should be
slash lord knowles
i'll talk to establish titles head on
over there become a lord or a lady
yourself
i'm so glad you like that clip that
makes me feel great that you liked it
you watched it now i hope you click the
like button i hope you i hope you like
maybe left me a comment but what i
really hope is
you ring the bell
that way you'll get the notifications we
can be together again and even if we
don't get the notifications for whatever
reason
youtube
you can head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play wherever
you get your audio podcasts
subscribe
leave a five star review
the michael knowles show
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you